god how are you i'm good i'm good we've
got drinks we've got food but first
let's talk about this is a neighborhood
style vibe 11 locations across the
valley what is distill and remedy all
about honestly it distill is it's a
family and you know get all your friends
together come have some really good food
we've got lots of specials going on for
the game
uh we have a lot of giveaways there are
locations that do have a restaurant site
so if you want to bring your family you
can go over there as well good good okay
so you mentioned touchdown worthy food
and drink i like that let's do the drink
what are we making so we're making a
southern gentleman today we're going to
start with some gentleman jack okay
we're going to pour in a little simple
syrup which is like liquid sugar good
make it a little sweet
this is lemonade just to give it some
okay splunk
and a little ginger beer
and i want you to put that blueberry
syrup on top just to make it pretty
syrup
boom how much do i do that's good that's
good you just want to give it another
color
i like it because it's rams colors
that's cool i like that a lot okay and i
hear there's prizes and giveaways and
giant tvs just talk about what people
can get besides the food and drink uh
you can get i my store is actually
giving away a cornhole board we've got
we've got t-shirts
uh gosh i don't even know what they gave
me every time you gotta go there to find
out buckets
coolers
dope okay good good so we got everything
you got everything for us locals
tourists alike come down to the stills
or remedies how should they make
reservations or
first come first serve but there's not a
bad seat in the house every tv can be
seen from any seat oh i like that i like
that who are you going for on sunday
bangles i always hold on
girl for the underdog all right fine
jc i'll send it over to you
am i too early is he still getting ready
for sin city chronicles it's okay it's
fine it's fine it's fine so can we just
break down these dishes really quick
well jc is getting ready we've got our
appetizer platter with sliders onion
rings mozzarella sticks and chicken
fingers okay our bourbon glaze burger
that looks fire right there blueberry
cream cheese sriracha glazed bacon sweet
potato fries oh my god can i try and
guess what this is yeah exactly
is that salmon no it's pork wow pork
belly okay i'm way off way off way off
okay tell us about that
so this is our pig candy it's glazed
with the bourbon as well it looks so
good it's my favorite absolutely
it is my favorite okay distills and
remedies thank you colleen you did great
davey now i'm sending it to you